I feel like we're kind of floating
around like a encouragement ferry today
just kind of like did it do it you go I
believe in you they're us hey what's up
I'm Joe Joe and I'm here to spread mad
love through as many random acts of
kindness as I can squeeze in while I'm
here at BuzzFeed we're gonna start
spreadin mad love with just some kind of
affirmative words you are worthy Shh
stick well have that head let's go let's
just make somebody dick some girl named
Joe Joe she happened to give me a little
sticky note passing good vibes and I've
made my day
okay come follow me let's go say hi to
the BuzzFeed employees come on
[Music]
and I was like nah this thing's a real
Jojo and then it turned out to be the
real Jojo and so I fangirl and lost my
cool and I appreciate it because now I
can look at my photo album on my phone
and see that my eighth-grade dreams came
true keep it up guys keep killing it I'm
inside the heart love rainbow and we're
gonna step it up and not to introduce
puppies into the equation hey what the
hell it's Jojo I just want to see if you
might be happy with a puppy I feel like
I blacked out like I want to recount
what happened but I can't really because
I know I acted a fool Twinkle Twinkle
[Music]
and her voice is literally like if
someone was just gonna lightly insert
honey into your earlobe that's what it
sounds like twinkle twinkle so I walked
into lunch today and lo and behold
there's Jojo standing in the kitchen
like comes up to us like gives us all
these compliments told us that she was
walking around and just like making
people happy for the day basically and
like gave us our bowls and our Forks and
she looked Baba's [ __ ] I kind of feel
like kindness is contagious because once
I started giving out compliments and
affirmations they started coming right
back to me so makes me feel like we
should really kind of do this all the
time well that's it for me at BuzzFeed
and just keep spreading mad love every
day you can and until next time I'll see
you around the streets spreading random
acts of kindness wanted to ask for a
phone number but she offered an email
but she's nice